pictures that we're receiving from the
Dartford Crossing in East London to
climate protesters who brought the
crossing basically to a standstill have
now agreed we understand to climb down
from uh the bridge the police had
brought in a platform which they were
going to use to in some sort of
operation to bring them down the men
from the just stop oil group climbed uh
the bridge yesterday forcing the closure
of the crossing which is the only way to
cross the Thames east of London by Road
our climate change and energy
correspondent Hannah Thomas Peter is in
The Newsroom and Hannah this would not
have been an easy operation for the
police but they needed to do something
because this protest has caused traffic
chaos
do chaos I mean it's been shut for two
days
um the Dartford Crossing causing miles
of tailbacks and hours and hours of
delays as these two men from the just
stop oil
um protest group climbed up quite close
to the top of the bridge and locked
themselves on I think what we can see
here is the removal of one of the
protesters whose name is Marcus he
hasn't given his second name to Sky News
but he's 33 years old and he is a
teacher
um being brought down now by Essex
police who've actually just released a
statement on on Twitter from Chief
superintendent Simon anslow who said I
know that this situation is incredibly
frustrating but we're doing everything
possible to resolve this situation as
quickly and safely as possible but we
are not in any way anti-protest however
it is unacceptable for people to think
that they can put lives in danger and
selfishly stop others going about their
lives and the public rightly expect us
to take action against anyone who
believes they can do this and we will so
what's happened in this situation is the
just stop oil protesters have been in
contact with the police and they've had
I've spoken to to one of them
um They Carried a number of ropes up the
bridge I understand that those ropes
weren't actually long enough to get them
down safely and so they've been in
contact with the police about how to how
to come down and the Essex police agreed
that they would provide a cherry picker
in in order to do so as safely as
possible the person who's still up in
the bridge is a man called Morgan
trollland and he is 39 years old and he
is a bridge engineer and earlier in the
day I interviewed him about why he was
doing this
I'm doing this because now's the moment
for civil resistance we've got two to
three years left to turn this this
around otherwise you know everything we
love is is gone is dying for the rest of
our lives so that's why we're taking
these drastic actions right now
yeah and the pictures uh Hannah that
we're seeing now is of uh one of them
coming down and the protests essentially
well they did say they were going to
stay up there until uh the government
gave undertakings that it would halt all
new oil and gas licenses and consents
yes I I mean that's what they they
always say that is the stated aim of
their group it's very narrow it's quite
different to Extinction Rebellion which
is a a very broad Church of a protest
group with lots of different demands but
just stop oil is exactly that they they
want the British government to say no
new oil and gas licenses no new oil and
gas extraction from the North Sea no new
Shale gas revolution of course it puts
them entirely at odds with the
conservative government's plans for
ushering in a new era of fossil fuel
exploration of the UK amidst an energy
security crisis and just stop oil argue
that the United Nations and other
agencies say that in order to keep 1.5
degrees of warming and within height in
order to limit the very worst of global
warming no new fossil fuel can be
extracted and that the UK is failing in
its moral and practical obligations by
even considering expanding oil and gas
drilling in the North Sea and for
example and they are getting
increasingly inventive and daring in
their tactics they are usually focused
on massive disruption and I think as a
mistake to worry about what they think
about the public and the Public's
support you know the point of this for
for these protesters as they told me a
number of times have been out with them
on on a number of protests the point is
to cause disruption and outrage in order
to keep the conversation going and
focused on their cause
but what's happening now which is
interesting is that in addition to these
Mass disruption protests climbing
Bridges locking themselves to oil
terminals breaking into oil terminals
gluing themselves to roads and so one
they're also starting to Target cultural
institutions and we saw that earlier in
the week didn't we when a couple of
activists threw a can of soup on Vincent
Van Gogh's sunflowers painting in the
National Gallery and glued themselves to
it now of course they knew that the
painting was protected by glass but it
was designed to cause to provoke outrage
and and to gain attention because a
number of these protesters told me
recently that they actually feel that
their standard tactics of blocking roads
and that certainly happened earlier
today in London just aren't getting the
attention they want so they are now
starting to put themselves at increasing
risk for a cause they believe in but of
course it's causing huge public backlash
the Prime Minister has condemned it the
police often say that they put
themselves and police officers in danger
and that they suck up huge amounts of
time and resources and there is real
public dismay around these actions I
have to say a lot of people who support
the cause but but real difficulty for
lots of people in accepting the the huge
amount of disruption
to daily life as people try and go about
their business
yeah and we just saw Hannah uh one of
the protesters being put into a police
van no doubt under arrest and the other
one is coming down I should just say
Anna that a statement has been issued by
those two protesters saying we
successfully disrupted oil supplies to
Kent and the southeast of 36 hours and
we're stepping down now but other
supporters of just stopped oil will be
stepping up day after day causing
disruption and putting their Liberty on
the line to demand that the government
ends new oil and gas so we'll leave the
police to sort out that last protester
that was their statement and that is the
scene at the Dartford Crossing